this is of course a very sad time after
this uh awful tragedy what's been
happening today
yeah so today we've been hearing from
family and also a friend of shazada and
his son Suleiman
it was very moving there was a prayer
too but mainly this was about Stories We
heard from Christine shazada's wife we
were told how they had met at a barbecue
in the year 2000 and that they married
two years later to the day and Christine
spoke of the moment that shazada held
their newborn son for the very first
time
he then held his son for the first time
I just knew these two Belong Together
his expression was like
that he found a long-lost companion
these past few days have been incredibly
challenging for us as a family
so emotions from excitement shock to
Hope and finally to Despair and grieve
and Christine also spoke of the time
that the Father and Son headed off in
the Titan it was like two best friends
she said embarking on their final
Journey but we heard two from shazada's
father Hussein clearly also a
grandfather who thanked all of those
who've sent messages of love and support
from across the globe he also remembered
the three other men and their loved ones
who had died on board the Titan and what
was quite clear as he spoke through the
tears was the the depth of this loss is
really hard to comprehend
such a situation what does the father
say
and a grandfather
both of them so excited
so terribly excited about
going to see the Titanic
it's amazing
messages are not only exhibited
a spirit or entrepreneurship
with a high spirit
of exploration
now we've got a real sense of the man
that shazada was from his close friend
he'd been friends since 18 With inam Ur
Rahman who said that shazada's death had
left a gaping void in his life he said
that his friend was incredibly
intelligent he was a lateral thinker a
man with enormous a enormous empathy Who
challenged himself than those around him
at all times and we heard as well
thoughts about Suleiman who was
described by this friend as a sensible
and respectful young man up who operated
at a level Beyond his age and he also
told us a little bit about how Suleiman
had planned a world record attempt he
wanted to solve the Rubik's Cube 3700
meters down below the surface of the of
the ocean and he said how he hoped he
would be teaching Angels how to solve
the Rubik's Cube in 15 seconds or less